I think we blame our friends and say
well they crap on our ideas and we don't
do it well before that happens we crap
on our own ideas you look at that list
and say I can't do that who was that
yesterday this crazy person that I used
to be who thought I could do that it's
ourselves telling ourselves that we suck
the problem is we've taken on that voice
and we think that it's us that's not
your voice that is not your voice
telling you that you suck that is
somebody else's voice that was planted
in your head that has been conditioned
to be there that we're so used to being
there there that we have taken on as our
voice it has become your identity but it
was not your voice it was put there you
need to rip that weed out it's other
people with low expectations who hate
their own lives who at some point went
and tried something that did not work
out and now nobody around them can have
success because it makes them look and
feel bad